so you guys asked for more developer
stuff on the lobby
last week Steve gainer the creator or
one of the many craters at the fulbright
company those who made gone home was in
town gone home is coming out today on
Xbox one and PlayStation 4 so we got him
in to talk about gone home I want better
way to talk about on home than playing
the gone home map in counter-strike so
this is a video of me and Steve talking
about gains with that guns that are in
first-person while playing gone home in
counter-strike enjoy hello folks and
welcome to a very special episode of we
play with developers games in
counter-strike Steve gainer you created
a wonderful video game which not many
people played but it did go on to create
the biggest counter-strike map in the
history of CS III I like to think of it
as our legacy you can obviously play
this on PC you can play it on console
yeah soft Tuesday yeah gone home is out
this week on Xbox one and PlayStation 4
the thing is like that I really
appreciate about this is I feel like
just from playing it but it's a real
kind of labor of love you know it's it's
been put in yeah it's a no it's it feels
like an homage or you know just like
really trying to yeah like right here on
my screen you'll remember in gone home
there's this light and there's this
little crucifix next to it and he just
used level geometry to put this little
crucifix
oh yeah look at that that's also yeah so
you know those kind of things go a long
way so check in so is this gonna be in
here let's find out that secret isn't in
there but I can probably just Rob this
to do it yeah there we go
so you get pestered you get down there
get down god I keep walking into this
room with this would just pull the
[ __ ] it's like this is the worst made
CS map ever it's like dead ends
everywhere it's almost like it's almost
like it was never intended for anyone to
play an FPS and what is this so if
people stopped giving a [ __ ] about it
being a walking simulator no no it's
just more people are making walking
simulators trendsetter
Firewatch and the witness yeah
are coming out in the next couple months
we had a guy maybe it's like soma feel
yeah oh you know Keynesian amnesia was
an influence on us you know it's a Brian
the horror game but it's a non-combat
horror game your only abilities are you
know walk around hide mmm find lamp oil
and that's and that's cool like amnesia
was one of the games that showed us like
oh yeah you know they're doing something
unique with a non combat first-person
experience dear Esther did something
unique with that first person experience
30 flights of loving they're all of
these reference points and I think you
know those games and Stanley parable and
you know other stuff that that has come
out in the interim I think has kind of
popularized the idea of there's a lot we
can do here you know like we're we're
working on Tacoma for our next game
there's a drift that's coming out which
is like a floating simulator yeah I mean
but I think that why I think it's one of
those terms we're walking simulator kind
of started as like a burn yes and then
it's like well it's actually just that
it's what we got like that's the best
name for it you walk around and stuff
happens it's cool and it's now an
established genre but actually a bunch
of quite good games in it yeah what's
the fastest you've ever completed going
home
49 second yeah so if that's if the
through line is that there's no guns
like especially as somebody who's worked
on Bioshock which are you know wonderful
narrative games which some people
especially infinite have said the kind
of work maybe are they hamstrung by the
fact that they need to have shooting and
well or you know people are at least
like oh the best you know the best part
of infinite was when you weren't
shooting the first hour so yeah I think
that kind of on the opposite side of it
you know I I was the lead and writer of
Minerva's Den it was the DLC for
Bioshock 2 antastic DLC as well I mean
we were yeah we were really proud of it
and you know in a lot of ways oh my god
I just noticed I'm sorry in the top
corner there's the mini-map and I made
it the Maps
from Ghana that's very good I had
noticed that he played through the whole
game you get through that all the way
through the power curve of a Bioshock
game you beat the boss of Minerva's Den
and then the last you know 10 15 minutes
10 minutes of the game are you go down
into Porter's office and your your guns
go down and it's just about you being an
environment yeah listening to an audio
diary exploring this evidence of what
was in this guy's personal space and
what it meant to him and so you know we
were kind of I think starting to explore
the idea of what's Bioshock without guns
yeah as kind of the Dino Maul of a
Bioshock experience in that case and you
know in infinite it was like the
introduction to a Bioshock experience
and I think that's something that I
really need to buy guns like you can use
I just keep coming out with my shitty
Glock and I'm like why do I keep dying
oh right because I would guys have like
a salt rifle well we're also doing an
interview and we can to your gameplay
either I think those are bad excuses for
us being bad at games yeah that'll be
the headline gone home creator sucks at
real games and that's part of what we
were going for was saying like we want
to see what it's like to have you know a
game where the heart of the experience
is the non-combat story explanation and
that it is intentionally like a small
focused single you know arc where it's
like okay I played through this in a few
hours and I could really delve into it
and now I feel like some closure you
know like I actually I started and this
thing and I played it over the course of
one you know long you know evening of
gameplay or a couple of days and I
really felt like I got to like fully
internalize all of that and feel like I
had a complete experience
yeah does the limit from that come from
the fact that it's it's difficult to
hold people's attention if they're not
engaging in that sort of combat or does
the limit not come from that's just the
best type of narrative experience you
can make is that it is dense and it it
does sort of wrap off the performer
stays it's finding it's a few different
things in our case so by the way kitchen
good pizza box in the place where
there's a pizza box in the game good
refrigerator so I think for us it was
both because we needed to build a small
game
we are a small team of course doing it
on our own resources which are you know
limited but you know I think there is
some real value to having a the length
of a story especially like a you know
small personal story be this is what
grenade party happening here be be like
focused and not overstate as welcome I
think we don't know if we could make
this be good or not long 12 hours if we
wanted to so it's kind of good that we
can't because they're like we're just
gonna do the best we can as making a few
hours long and and having the density of
the the experience so you feel like
every room is really filled with a lot
of stuff that's worth seeing you know
you don't feel like well here's just
another empty room here's one thing with
like one you know one note in it it's
good we just you can see what the
witness ends up doing them because that
might be a question that that answers
yeah I think if you like the witness is
you know a lot of land mass a lot of
kind of ambient exploration and I think
that that's you know that's partly what
the puzzle aspect is is about you know
it'll be really interesting to see yeah
what what that really means I think in
practice I'm lucky so does this ever
make you think all we should have made
like a competitive gone home experience
yes well I can come over like a clock I
just shot my friend it was me know your
parents coming back no that was oh this
was why the house was empty because
someone here [ __ ] I need to hi Kenny we
can we hide under the stairs no did you
get him
no I did mr. V always I can tell you
where he is oh he's your something we
can cheat yes stay there stay I'll tell
you when is gonna go around the corner
okay we're treating a just a that were
cheetahs only he's like five feet out
okay he's gonna be there three two
the final round okay it says final round
oh it does yeah yeah yeah all right this
is gonna be final round so it would for
77 oh [ __ ] you're in the attic yeah all
these stuck me downstairs oh no does a
dead person there already
[ __ ] you mr. V I'm gonna avenge you yes
I killed him Oh I'll [ __ ] some garbage
you killed him so garbage come [ __ ] oh
ho
don't kill Steve Steve made the game
this is based on the unites GSP oh man
no no no no right spray-and-pray I got I
got season's greetings in snow sucks is
not what's gonna happen this isn't
height this is like this is close yeah
77 gosh oh there's two of there's two
there's two of them and one of us up in
the attic how fitting that the game
ending yeah an epic showdown in the
Attic congratulations mr. V no ray Frank
bullet 67 congratulations gone home kind
of strike community yeah congratulations
another great home yeah it is in this
incredibly popular competitive map